pour commencer ce sens public je vous
propose un résumé en images de cette
journée de consultation et de cogitation
avec norbert évangéliste à
sourire de façade pour ce qui devait
être un jour de conseil pour les
ministres du gouvernement transformé en
simple réunion de travail après le
chamboulement des élections législatives
à la manoeuvre une chef de gouvernement
ont confirmé à son poste démission
refusée malgré le protocole par un chef
de l'état pressé de travailler sur des
mesures d'urgence avec un mot d'ordre
nous avons été vu par le peuple français
pour gouverner nous gouvernons sous
l'autorité des abbés de bornes et du
présent de 10 alors qu'avec une priorité
pouvoir d'achat la protection des
français face à l'augmentation des prix
l'essence l'électricité le gaz des
mesures sur lesquelles emmanuel macron à
court de majorité doit à tout prix
obtenir le soutien d'autres formations
du nouvel échiquier politique
si leur chef de parti reçu dès
aujourd'hui à l'elysée reste ferme sur
leur place de force d'opposition des
discussions semblent possibles mais à
chacun son camp chacun ses conditions
mais moi je souhaite que nous soyons
tous et tous utiles à ce pays et donc je
suis venu le dire que le pays n'est pas
bloqué il ya des réformes qui sont
bloqués et celle qu'il avait peut-être
proposer de manière précipitée mais il y
avait une volonté
chez nous d'aller en avant je pouvoir
d'achat par exemple et donc si le
président est par exemple disposer à
porter le smic à 1500 euros il aura une
majorité pro ceux-là jamais on ne sera
dans le blocage des institutions où
notre position sur la retraite peut elle
est connue
il y à une nécessité de relever les
pensions de ré indexer les retraites
mais ça ça peut se faire qu'avec une
réforme des retraites et ceux qui
veulent raconte qu'on va ramener l'âge
de départ légal à 60 ans et augmenter
les pensions se fiche du monde et se
fiche des français les proches du parti
présidentiel veulent croire qu'il est
possible de dépasser les clivages et
placer l'intérêt de la france au dessus
de tout devant les difficultés très
grande qui nous attendent
il faut s'approcher aussi près que
possible de l'union nationale
je sais très bien que l'union nationale
au sens propre c'est pas totalement
approprié à la période il ya eu des
campagnes électorales il ya eu des
confrontations il ya eu des
affrontements
mais au moins chacun doit se sentir
on part de responsabilité dans ce qui
vient ce qui vient la fin des
consultations des partis jusqu'à demain
en attendant un diagnostic du chef de
l'état très attendue par tous les
français
et on débat tout de suite autour de
cette actualité politique claire
chartier bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste et essayiste bruno cautrès
autres bourses mais politologue
chercheur au cnrs et au cevipof pablo
pino vignes un bonsoir bienvenue si vous
êtes responsable éditorial de la revue
regards et lætitia krupa éditorialiste
politique bonsoir laetitia on démarre
évidemment par ces consultations
emmanuel macron qui reçoit les chefs de
partis à l'elysée claire chartier alors
on peut dire c'est de la com on peut
dire c'est un passage obligé où on peut
dire c'est un moyen de sonder en direct
en face à face les intentions d'alliés
potentiels vous dites quoi un peu des
trois alors un peu des trois et puis
alors il ya quand même qui effectivement
quelque chose qui a ressorti déjà là
d'emblée de ces consultations viens
d'entendre christian jacob qui jusque là
disait répétait martelait qu aucun
accord n'était possible avec la macro ni
et qui vient quand même là dans sa
déclaration d'indiquer que
le texte sur les retraites ce texte là
pourra peut-être faire l'objet d'un
accord donc c'est quand même déjà une
avancée on a aussi entendu olivier faure
dont on a déjà un petit peu bougé par
rapport à la situation même de ce matin
donc effectivement ça laisse présager
peut-être d'une situation où la majorité
va pouvoir trouver des accords des
majorités de circonstance comme on dit
aucun texte car texte et pourquoi pas en
fait enfin ça c'est déjà beaucoup dit
mais effectivement c'est un changement
de culture mais on y reviendra mais mais
pourquoi pas assez c'est une évolution
totalement perdu l'habitude notamment
depuis le passage au quinquennat mais
mais ça existe
oui ça existe et notamment bon moi qui
ai vécu en espagne j'étais
correspondante en espagne et en espagne
ce qu'un régime parlementaire donc
effectivement c'est difficile ce genre
de régime parce que vous partez d'emblée
avec l'idée que vous allez devoir
pactiser passer des compromis lorsque j
étais le gouvernement qui était de
droite de lait sans arrêt travailler son
son versant catalan pour avoir des
pivots donc c'était compliqué ça prend
un peu de temps mais après ça donne des
textes qui en fait en gage ceux qui
l'ont signé donc c'est important parce
que ça donne une forme de stabilité mais
après effectivement balle à l'exemple
espagnol ces dernières années la montre
et c'est que ça n'est pas de tout repos
non plus parce que les espagnols n'ont
pas été arrêté d'aller aux urnes pendant
quatre ans donc effectivement c'est
toute une culture qu'il faut apprendre
et je pense qu'on en sommes aux prémices
et je m'en réjouis personnellement bruno
cautrès on a aussi entendu françois
bayrou
le prix en du modem sortir de son rendez
vous avec avec emmanuel macron alors lui
il est plus habituée peut-être que que
christian jacob ou de fouquereuil il est
fort évidemment mais c'est intéressant
quand il dit l'union nationale la
question c'est sûr qu'elle arc politique
voyez ce que je veux dire ben oui parce
que ce thème de l'unité nationale nous
font tout le monde est pour on enfonce
un peu une porte ouverte où les français
sont pour de l'unité nationale donc
après c'est qu'est ce qu'on met derrière
ce mot d'unité nationale quel est le
périmètre de la discussion et là on voit
qu'à une variable systémique française
qui quand même différencier des autres
démocraties européennes
effectivement je partage votre avis dans
plein d'autres pays européens ça se
pratique mais vous avez dit quelque
chose d'essentiel qui était on sait dès
le départ c'est ap or nous personne n'a
fait campagne sur le thème ce que je
suis en train de vous dire fera l'objet
d'une réactualisation une fois que
l'élection sera passé et ce point est un
point assez fondamental parce qu'en
arrière-fond ya quand même la crise de
confiance des français dans l'action
publique dans les politiques avec mais
alors moi j'ai voté pour qu'ils
défendent cette idée puis finalement où
il accepte de négocier
avant de ce point de vue là ça change
quand même un peu les choses ou alors il
faudrait tout une méthode saurait
remettre une un élément qui commence
retourner vers les électeurs comment
expliquer ça il faut peut-être du temps
pour que une forme de pédagogie qui se
fait là dessus et là on voit qu'on a
besoin de temps pour frais cette
adaptation et puis peut-être que ce sera
pas qu'une question de temps ça serait
peut-être un jour la question
institutionnelle un peu plus profonde et
évidemment on va on va à l'évoquer aussi
dans cette émission notamment de notre
second débat toute la partie
constitution et levier outils armes
employons n'importe quelle expression en
possession de l'exécutif pour malgré
tout continuer d'avancer ou de voudrait
former je reste sur ces consultations
pablo pino il vient quand quand olivier
faur sort il dit j'espère que ce n'est
pas une mise en scène on sera sans doute
fixé dans quelques jours parce que pour
l'instant on ne peut pas on n'a pas
encore entendu emmanuel macron alors il
nous a déjà promis plusieurs fois et un
changement de méthode donc voilà enfin
de la sueur et juger sur pièce mais là
entre temps il ya eu et eu quand même un
séisme politique oui effectivement on a
à peine entendus elisabeth bornes le
soir du premier tour on sait toujours
pas effectivement à quelle sauce on sera
mangé
mais pour rebondir en fait sur tout ce
qui vient d'être dit par rapport au
blocage institutionnel potentiels
auxquels la france pourrait faire face
et d'un autre côté voilà ces alliances
au cas par cas car il ya quand même le
problème central c'est un poème d'une
culture politique mais c'est aussi un
problème de lorsque vous écoutez à la
fois olivier faure jean luc mélenchon
pour pour la nuit baisse mais de l'autre
côté de l'échiquier politique
les cadres des des républicains ou du
rassemblement national tous le disent
ils disent mais nous on a vocation à
gouverner donc pourquoi est ce qu'on
ferait plaisir finalement à emmanuel
macron en l'aidant finalement à
gouverner et en réfléchissant et en
faisant avancer le pays mais avec lui
qui est à la tête de l'état pourquoi est
ce que nous on devrait accepter ça et
c'est une vraie question c'est est
rachida dati tandis qu'à gauche r oui je
suis pas une béquille mais exactement au
pardon vous interrompez sauf si ce que
vous citez accepte de faire partie d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale il
faudrait qu'ils acceptent ils vous vers
les j'imagine qu'ils ont mis dans la
balance un certain nombre de réflexions
qu'il faudra mener mais en fait il ya la
question effectivement de l'intérêt
général de la france et des français et
des françaises d'une part d'autre part
il ya l'intérêt de faire avancer
finalement leurs idées et leurs
propositions mais troisièmement essais
non négligeable il ya aussi l'intérêt de
faire avancer leur formation politique
et demain par exemple si on prend les l
air ce qui aujourd'hui on a l'impression
qu'ils sont le plus proche
idéologiquement de ce que pourrait
proposer une année de macron j'en prends
pour preuve ce qu'a dit christian jacob
sur la réforme des retraites on a
l'impression qu'ils pourraient la signer
le problème c'est que s'ils commencent à
dire bon bah c'est bon c'est parti on
peut on va taupe et on va rentrer dans
votre gouvernement etc
la fin des républicains parce qu'il dit
finalement en fait ce qui s'est passé
depuis cinq ans c'est déjà
la préfiguration a fait de ce que
c'était que la droite donc c'est
compliqué pour dans le cadre du
fonctionnement même de leur propre parti
et c'est le cas pour pour les autres
c'est le cas aussi pour je sais pas moi
d'aider des députés danube est ce qui
pourrait être tenté de dévaliser
certains textes proposés par par le bar
tard crise en ciel clair chartier le
raisonnement qu'on fait sur l air on va
peut-être se retrouver à le faire dans
quelques jours sur le parti socialiste
qui s'est pour l'instant où il est fort
dit le smic à 1500 valvo témoins
évidemment ce n'est pas du tout dans le
programme de lehman et le maquereau mais
bon
on sait pas c'est une ère d'incertitude
qui s'ouvre aussi pour aussi pour nous
donc cet arc politique de l'union
nationale dont on parle et qui sait
peut-être que dans quinze jours on se
dira il va jusqu au parti socialiste oui
pu aller aussi de l'autre côté oui
jusqu'au rassemblement national ça
j'imagine mal le parti saisit accepter
un gouvernement
allant dans ce sens là aujourd'hui enfin
c'est quand même alors là
particulièrement déconcertant où la
majorité pourrait effectivement bas
c'est ce que veut dire d'ailleurs
pourrait trouver des accords avec le
rassemblement national sur certains
textes après avoir quand même tapé à
fond sur le rassemblement national pour
permettre emmanuel macron vous croyez
plus à ce cas de figure cas
car un texte sur lequel le parti
socialiste pourrait voter c'est
intéressant en tout cas je trouve ça
tout à fait surprenant de lire sa fin
quand même mettez nous mettons nous à la
place des électeurs c'est vrai que c'est
totalement déconcertant coll parce que
ce front républicain il a quand même un
peu fonctionné on dit qu'il est mort etc
mais au moment de la présidentielle il a
quand même fonctionné suffisamment pour
qui manuel macron passe donc il ya de
cela quelque chose et maintenant on nous
dit ça alors c'est vrai que c'est tout à
fait déconcertant en ce qui concerne l
air par rapport aux cas étrangers dont
on parle c'est vrai que l air ce qui
s'est passé chez leurs ces dernières
années c'est que la partie modérée les
parties en fait ils sont faits et
éviscérés donc évidemment là dans l'eure
dans leurs problématiques à eux
spécifique là c'est certain que il est
vraiment question de l'assurance la
survie de l air de l'autre côté on peut
imaginer enfin moi je trouve ça assez
envisageable que certaines voix de
gauche dans cette nuque qui est quand
même très hétéroclite et qui dote déjà
commencent à exploser enfin à peine
avant avions-nous le résultat que ça
commençait à a sauté donc on peut penser
que sur certains dossiers les
écologistes et certains socialistes puis
ce signe effectivement s'allier se
retrouver si on certain taxer pas c'est
pas inenvisageable
moi je trouve ça beaucoup plus
surprenant enfin dans le panneau à part
actuelle ce que je disais à l'instant de
du rassemblement national oui c'est il
faut il faut expliquer peut-être bruno
cautrès il ya effectivement eu quelques
appels du pied notamment on écoutera
tout à l'heure un eric dupond moretti
dans une interview qui arrive c'est pour
mourir quand même comme qui est
effectivement fer de lance de lentilles
lepénisme interdite
lors d'élections dans le nord est qui
diront peut-être que ce texte leur
pourrait selon pourrait se mettre
d'accord une de mes réformes justice
c'est comment vous l'avez on voit tout
de suite à quel point tout ça va donner
un tableau un patchwork e1 décodable par
les français par les électeurs c'est
assez dire extrêmement problématique
puisqu'au fond
emmanuel macron n'a eu de cesse depuis
2010 est de nous dire que rien n'était
plus dangereux que le nationalisme
belliqueux dit-il même moment des
élections européennes pendant la
campagne des européennes de 2019 pour
parler de la liste jordan bardella les
nationalistes belliqueux donc c'est vrai
que là c'est extrêmement étrange sinon
seuls qu'on se dit mme en fait les
nationalistes b que sont des gens
intéressants sur certains aspects voilà
donc assez c'est ce que je voulais dire
total en dix ans il ya un vrai gros
travail de pédagogie la grande
différence avec le cas de l'allemagne
dont on ne cesse de demander ces camps
en allemagne à des mois qui se qui
s'écoule entre les élections à la
formation du gouvernement est au fond ce
temps il est intéressant parce que ce
temps ceux ci le temps que les électeurs
s'approprie que les électeurs des
différents camps disent bah oui sont en
train de négocier il ya des points de
notre programme qui vont être mis à
l'agenda du goût du gouvernement
et ça c'est pas du tout le cas
c'est une façon totalement c'est pas du
tout ça dont on est en train de parler
en france on entende parler d'une sorte
de cas par cas au fond le gouvernement
veut faire sur ces textes adoptés en
faisant adopter quelques amendements
peut-être mais c'est pas des
propositions d opposition qui vont être
défendue par elisabeth bornes ou alors
là il ya un vrai problème qui va se
poser qui est où est la feuille de route
des lisbonne comment elle est définie on
parle là il ya des acteurs économiques
pour les acteurs économiques il faut
qu'ils aient un paysage un peu un peu
claires pour l'été
c'est ce qu'elle va être la pression
fiscale dans deux ans voilà donc il ya
un moment donné un peu un tableau un peu
confus qui peut sortir de tout ça alors
vous parlez d isabelle borne ouvrir ce
chapitre dans dans ce premier débat de
sens public quel destin pour il avait
deux bornes elle a présenté sa démission
au président de la république emmanuel
macron l'a aussitôt refusée en demandant
je le cite au gouvernement de rester à
sa tâche est de continuer d'agir
il avait deux bornes et elle sur un
siège éjectable avant de vous donner la
parole et d'abord à laetitia on écoute
olivier grégoire c'était juste après la
réunion des ministres à matignon elle
est au travail elle prépare les
prochains jours avec le gouvernement
l'ensemble des décrets que nous devons
en sortir je sais pas si par exemple on
vous a cité le décret apprentissage on a
sept cent mille apprentis des
entreprises qui attendent que la prime
soit reconduite le gouvernement doit
être au travail c'est ce que nous
faisons elle consultera et elle sera
présent demain au parlement en rayon et
la semaine prochaine avec les forces
politiques c'est donc une première
ministre au travail cette semaine et la
semaine prochaine message est clair pour
olivier grégoire laetitia donc il ya eu
alors ce geste je présente ma démission
le président lui refuse est ce que ça
veut dire qu'elle qu'elle ait là quoi
qu'il arrive elisabeth bornes non ça
veut juste dire que emmanuel macron part
sur une séquence internationale dans les
prochains jours entre bruxelles jusqu'à
madrid pour un sommet de l'otan en début
de semaine prochaine donc ça amène loin
et qu'il ne peut pas laisser le pays
sans première ministre et ce qui vaut à
dire sans gouvernement parce qu'il y
aurait trois postes quand même vacants
et pas des moindres celui de la mer la
santé la transition écologique donc
emmanuel macron c'est que pour l'instant
c'est impossible il est coincé il a
déjeuné hier et on a su avec elisabeth
borne ilv a confirmé sa confiance
aujourd'hui on l'a vu il a reçu les
principaux chefs de l'opposition mais
sans elle est juste pour quand même
rappeler se rafraîchir la mémoire qu'on
a décidément très courte il avait aussi
réitéré sa confiance à edouard philippe
avant de le congédier donc tout est
possible elle et vous avez raison thomas
sur un siège éjectable
c'est il ya un petit signe comme ça qui
trompe pas il ya deux interviews dont
une à paris match qui va être faite là
cette semaine avec elisabeth bornes
n'interdit un peu plus personnelle pour
briser l'armure ça c'est l'obsession des
politiques enfin on voit que l en tout
cas s'accroche à son siège de matignon
et que pour le moment emmanuel macron
n'a d'autre choix que de la garder et
c'est ce qu'on a vu dimanche soir
d'ailleurs dans son discours un très
court très court de second tour des
élections législatives on va l'écouter
c'était la fin du discours écouter la
première ministre avec le président de
la république nous allons oeuvrer dans
le dialogue à l'ecoute des françaises et
des français et de toutes les forces
vives partout et dans tous les
territoires
j'ai confiance dans notre pays
confiance en chacun de nous et en notre
esprit de responsabilité
nous avons tout pour réussir et c'est
ensemble que nous y parviendrons
cette grande respiration avant le g
confiance et quand même le canton on
sent que à l'isel est accrochée à son
texte une déclaration courte totalement
dévitalisés je ne sais pas ce que vous
en avez pensé mais j'étais stupéfaite
par le contenu de cette déclaration vide
absolument rempli avec des phrases
toutes faites qu'ils ne veulent rien
dire j'ai confiance une majorité
d'actions tout ça pour vous dire thomas
qu'on a senti qu'un vent de panique a
vraiment souffler sur l'elysée dimanche
soir parce que pour sortir ce texte là
mais vraiment d'une pauvreté j'invite
tout le monde à aller le réécouter elle
est quand même resté deux heures avec le
président en tête à tête donc c'est à
dire qu'on comprend qu'il y avait une
légère stupeur qui planait au dessus de
l'est dimanche bon donc vous pensez
qu'elle n'est absolument pas assuré de
rester en place et pas c'est pas la
tonalité des des réactions des analyses
de ces dernières c'est vrai quand on
écoute les commentaires qui sont au
frais un pour tous c'est à dire que
emmanuel macron s'il décide de se
séparer des bornes qui trouvera t-il
quelle femme parce qu'il y avait quand
même cet aspect là qui était
fondamentale quelle image aussi pour lui
s'il décide de s'en séparer aussi vite
images sur cette thématique ce sujet des
femmes et puis sur la malédiction de
matignon rappelez-vous edith cresson
première femme est seule femme avant
isabelle borne qui a retenu dix mois et
18 jours donc on comprend bien qu'il ya
énormément de contraintes qui contraint
finalement aussi le choix des manuels
macro mais nous sommes dans une crise
politique sans précédent encore pour le
quinquennat macro et donc personne ne
connaît l'issue effectivement claire
chartier qui tient le destin d'elisabeth
mende entre ses mains est ce que ce
serait pas christian jacob qui est
imparable oui deux fait effectivement si
si on part sur le scénario accord
gouvernemental accord de gouvernement
avec la droite alors là il n'y a aucune
raison qu'ils habitent bord nord-est
parce que non seulement c'est une femme
qui par sa trajectoire vient de la
gauche elle a travaillé avec ségolène
royal donc ça ne serait pas tout à fait
de l'agrément de l air et puis en plus l
air voudrait un premier ministre à sa
main donc logiquement il ya vingt ans
elle catherine vautrin par exemple donc
il n'y a aucune raison qu'elle a semé en
revanche alors bon là ça semble un petit
peu évolué mais on est quand même pas
parti sur ce chemin là pour l'instant et
à ce moment là elle peut rester parce
que effectivement c'est pas forcément
dans l'intérêt des modèles macron de
s'en débarrasser tout de suite est là
elle a fait preuve durant sa trajectoire
notamment lorsqu'elle dirigeait à la
ratp d'un certain sens de la négociation
du consensus si elle reste et donc si on
est sur le scénario de recherche
d'accords ponctuels il va falloir qu
effectivement elles fassent le boulot et
fasse le job auprès des députés et
qu'elle aille donc qu'elles fassent
preuve d'un sens de la négociation du
mot compromis et un sens politique alors
c'est peut-être là où les interrogations
se portent c'est à dire est elle
vraiment suffisamment politique dans le
film barré dans laquelle dans lequel
elle se trouve aujourd'hui pour mener à
bien ce type de tâche je n'en sais rien
mais au fond le problème c'est pas c'est
pas il est borgne sans même lui avait
quand même donné la mission de mener
cette bataille législative qui a été oui
sur le vraiment décevante 1 pour
reprendre les oui mais h du gouvernement
c'est une gifle une claque enfin bien
sûr les grands chelems c'est emmanuel
macron cinq ans même pas et la corse et
tous avec l'as cannes le chef de ces
métropoles mais on sait tous étonnés
kemal vaqueront soit à ce point absents
même si c'est le chef de l'état on est
d'accord a priori c'est pas la première
miss qui doit s'engager là dedans mais
c'est vrai que sur le fond c'est quand
même là la question qui est posée c'est
celle de la capacité d' emmanuel macron
à a commandé à exercer le pouvoir
autrement donc en amont elle paye un
petit peu je m'arrêterai là mais elle
paye pour véritablement cette difficulté
qui a émané d'un tronc finalement est ce
qu'on peut lui faire porter le chapeau
d'une stratégie cas pas quelqu'un qui
n'était pas forcément la sienne entre le
résultat de la présidentielle et le
premier tour des législatives oui c'est
clair que le responsable de toute cette
situation c'est l'ensemble de la
majorité avec son son grand chef
évidemment qu'elle en toile de fond de
l'eau de remarques sur elisabeth bornes
d'avant c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas
conduit la campagne des législatives pas
du tout dans sa circonscription la 6ème
du calvados face à un jeune
fille de 22 ans elle ne fait que 50 de
gauche sans voile à dimanche n'a pas un
mot pour les électeurs de sa
circonscription qui l'ont élu pas un
seul dont une situation qui était aussi
là aussi envoyé quand même sa difficulté
à incarner une fonction politique avec
la balle réflexe du politique c'est de
se retourner vers l'est vers les
électeurs donc là on va voir c'est un
vrai crash test pour elles au fond de
résistance à une situation politique
extrêmement complexe après sur les
stratégies des acteurs je pense que
personne aujourd'hui n'a un intérêt
stratégique à se lier les mains déjà
aujourd'hui au fond ils ont tous intérêt
à avoir une politique plutôt de assez
empirique dos tester voir si on peut
faire un bout de chemin avec les airs
sur la réforme des retraites et plus si
affinités comme on dit après hélas à ce
moment-là peut-être que la question du
dessin d'elisabeth bornes ne se reposera
nouveau et c'est intéressant
effectivement pablo pino bien parce que
tout le monde est face à une nouveauté
dans cette dans cette nouvelle assemblée
même elle est fille avec un groupe
beaucoup plus important que le précédent
elle est fille au sein de la nu le rn
avec 89 députés enfin bref c'est une
nouvelle histoire et il faut qu'ils
trouvent aussi leur place en tant
qu'opposant sur sur quel registre de
radicalité pour pour les deux extrêmes à
employer le terme d'aidé c'est tout à
fait juste on va attendre déjà de voir
comment les uns et les autres se
positionne dans cette nouvelle assemblée
les discours qui vont qu'ils vont ils
porter mais juste pour pour pour tenir
sur les abeilles de bornes il avait dans
le problème c'est que effectivement est
là elle avait été nommée pour être un
peu l'aiguillon en fait de la nouvelle
majorité qu aurait pu voir
crépus voilà arrivés à l'assemblée
nationale le 19 juin prochain le brent
et qu'aujourd'hui elle en est plus aiguë
elle en est elle devrait en être le
barycentre et on n'a pas les moyens
parce que effectivement comme vous
l'avez rappelé elle vient plutôt de la
gauche en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'à
droite on imagine on imagine et
aujourd'hui les alliances vont se faire
à droite donc anaïs à son poste à son
poste en fait de chef de gouvernement ça
n'a plus de sens et là il navigue à vue
après il ya les symboles et quand même
exactement le symbole qui était
peut-être fameux v avait évoqué ici même
juste à damian je suis d'accord une
femme elle fait référence aux rêves des
petites filles dans son premier discours
lors de l'association de pouvoir avec
jean castex le symbole que ce serait de
la part des mails macron de sa virée
pardon d'être un peu triviale mais on
sait que ce serait a besoin de moi même
s'il ya des raisons politiques objets
que oui parce qu'en fait ça serait une
terrible ce serait terrible à plat sa
stratégie mais effectivement il ya eu
ces symboles il ya eu ces quelques
déplacements ces quelques discours mais
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu beaucoup de
gens mais beaucoup de gens de la
majorité dire oui il faut qu'elles
puissent continuer à agir et à elle a
fait quoi en fait qu'est ce qui se fait
passer depuis ma depuis qu'elle est
depuis qu'il est chef du gouvernement
et depuis qu'il ya un nouveau
gouvernement nettement je suis bien
incapable de dire mais de donner un
décret ou une action en fait qu'ils
auraient mené ensuite la campagne de
louis seigner je suis période de réserve
je suis d'accord mais lorsqu'on me dit
il faut qu'elles puissent continuer à
agir 2010 une comptine mais quoi en fait
qu'elle commence déjà à agir qu'elle
nous dise quelle parce que c'est ça
aussi le propre frère laetitia notait
que son discours était particulièrement
vide mais en fait qu'elles nous disent
exactement en fait la feuille de route
qu'elle donne à ses différents ministres
à feuille de route qu elle ce qu'elle se
donne peut-être à elle même pour pour
mener ce gouvernement est aujourd'hui
vraiment même sur la réforme des
retraites on n'a toujours pas compris
qu'elle était l'agent d'actes manqués
lancera des modèles très universel a
aujourd'hui je suis complètement
d'accord mais c'est peut-être là son
rôle aujourd'hui si jamais
rien annoncer enfin c'était injuste
c'était juste une
l encre enfin c'est une des reliques à
nantes vous avise mais vous avez vous
mettez tout à fait le doigt sur le
problème institutionnel aujourd'hui
auxquels on est confrontés c'est à dire
que on a une chef de gouvernement qui
est incapable de prendre aujourd'hui de
livrer un discours clair précisément
parce qu'elle
savait mesure pouvoir d'achat quand même
elle a pris date elle a annoncé qu'en
même temps l'été
viendrait des choses très vite dans une
loi sanitaire aussi voilà d'ailleurs ce
texte là claire chartier il va être
intéressant parce que c'est un bon
indice avait un bon indicateur je
reprends ce que disait bruno cautrès
août à l'heure du positionnement de ces
nouvelles oppositions parce que tout le
monde se dit pouvoir d'achat il faut
faire c'est quelque chose c'est
peut-être un peu compliqué de justifier
auprès de ses électeurs qu'on n'a pas
voté un paquet pouvoir d'achat seulement
ça sera un pôle épreuve de vérité là on
verra quelle est finalement là l'esprit
de ces oppositions si c'est quand on ya
joué totalement la confrontation ou
avoir un esprit plus constructif que
créatif mais en fait emmanuel macron il
est exposé à une double difficulté c'est
d'abord il se trouve face à
effectivement une situation inédite
c'est à dire qu'on est dans un régime
qui répond à une grammaire
présidentialiste avec un une assemblée
qui aujourd'hui ne répondent plus à la
logique du fait majoritaire donc ça déjà
il ya une vraie mendient jonction qui
est très difficile et encore une fois
qu'il est historique ayant plus il est
face à des oppositions qui sont beaucoup
plus radical que jadis donc en effet
comment vont-elles se comporter à si on
regardait les filles son comportement
dans la législature précédente bon on
peut se dire que ça ne va pas être
simple et que effectivement l'aspect
constructif n'apparaît pas d'emblée
lorsqu'on y songe maintenant on a une
marine le pen qui elle présente sa est
dite ou qu'elle a véritablement envie
d'avancer pour le bien du pays donc là
une certaine manière elle ça elle
s'achemine vers une attitude beaucoup
plus je dirais pas que sinon tu mets en
tout cas comprend six afin de servir
l'état du pays donc du coup
effectivement une vraiment il ya une
incertitude qui se pose comment ils se
alors j'ajouterai qu'il ya un autre
élément c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
députés qui sont nouveaux enfin via une
un grand gouvernement à l'assemblée donc
il ya aussi comment dire une espèce de
d'habitus qu'il faut acquérir une
connaissance des rois jeu c'est
peut-être l'occasion pour ces gens qui
n'ont pas finalement pratiquer cette
logique antérieures où le compromis
n'était pas là ils vont découvrir autre
chose et peut-être que j'ose l'espérer
un certain sens de la responsabilité va
se faire je me suis juste avancer ces
deux grandes lois effectivement
attendues pour le juillet on oublie un
léger passage c'est un vote de
conscience de confiance au parlement je
dire c'est que général oui
d'accord mais enfin il va quand même se
passer quelque chose de bien sûr on est
bien si isabelle borne arrive avec son
discours de politique générale vous
pensez qu'il n'y aura pas de confiance
ça n'a pas engagé
d'accord mais enfin là ça voudrait dire
que quand même on change des règles
aussi du jeu politique depuis 1993 alors
une règle ou si tu ne concevait pas
obligé c'est l'objet faire jusqu'au de
politique générale mais pas dans la
plainte vote de confiance qui serait
effectivement un peu risqué la situation
dodo d'aujourd'hui et le contenu de son
discours va être extrêmement important
parce que normalement c'est dans le
discours de politique générale qu'elle
devrait développer la méthodologie pour
travailler avec les oppositions et donc
je pense que ça ça va complètement
changer d'orientation le discours de
politique générale qui sinon auraient
été simplement le déroulé du programme
présidentiel à jouer non voilà et c'est
ça et c'est pour ça au fond quand seront
effectivement est en train de se jouer
un peu quels sont les quelles sont les
lignes rouges l'ailé
les cadres casus belli on dit ça on n'y
touche pas parce qu'on sait qu'on va se
taper dessus et ça ça vous orienter pas
mal le discours de politique générale
est d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon il ya
quelques minutes redemande à a
elisabeth bande de se soumettre à un
vote de confiance pas blues puis olivier
ça va être intéressant cette motion de
censure que l efi a décidé de porter
alors pas on l'a déjà beaucoup commenté
hier on va pas revenir sur
on va dire la méthode mélenchon qui a
pas tout à fait consulter ses alliés
avant d'annoncer cette motion de censure
ou d'appeler à un groupe unique à
l'assemblée mais ça va être aussi une
façon de se compter pour les oppositions
exactement on va voir qui décident de
voter en faveur de cette motion censure
ou pas ça va être alors ça ils vont se
compter en fait dans les oppositions ils
vont se compter à l'intérieur même de la
nuit baisse on va voir qui suit en fait
cette motion censure ou pas c'est un peu
drôle jean luc mélenchon qui fasse kiki
qui est cette initiative dans la mesure
où il n'est plus député député app il
est député jusqu'à ce soir donc je sais
ça qui justifiait tout à l'heure ça à
l'assemblée nationale va regarder les
autres mais c'est vrai ça va perdre
après je suis pas sûr que ça que ça
aboutisse quelque part puisque on a
entendu les différents cas tordent et
des groupes d'opposition alors je sais
pas si l erc cochera lacroix fins médico
chat la case opposition ou pas au
gouvernement parce que c'est ça en fait
chaque groupe doit cocher une case est
ce qu'ils sont dans l'opposition où est
ce qu'ils sont à quand on arrive à
l'assemblée nationale je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont prochainement en tout cas
tous les groupes d'opposition ne vont
pas forcément participé oui on ne se
prononcent pas non ça je pense pas que
ce gaz existé mais en tout cas voilà par
rapport à cette motion de censure ils
vont devoir se positionner ils sont pas
tous d'accord cela c'est des questions
de méthode parce qu'ils peuvent
s'opposer au gouvernement tout en dit
tout en disant ben en fait on laissait
la possibilité quand même à ce
gouvernement d'exister dans la mesure où
on est on se serait comme un respect en
fait des règles démocratiques et
institutionnels alors même que il
souhaite quand même s'y opposer c'est ce
qu'a dit en substance olivier faur c'est
ce qu'a dit aussi en substance fabien
roussel du parti communiste et alors
vous y faisiez allusion c'est l'une des
images de de cette journée donc alors y
en a plusieurs j'ai commencé sa part
celle là sans les députés la france
insoumise le poing levé sur les marches
de l'assemblée y avait déjà eu cette
image il ya il ya cinq ans symbole
historique évidemment de la révolte
inspiré par le parti communiste allemand
né dans les années 20 en réaction à la
montée du nazisme et ensuite popularisé
par le parti communiste français ce
point levé
ça c'est l'une des premières images de
cette journée et puis on a affectivement
jean luc mélenchon elle ça vous a pas
échappé qui est au milieu des députés le
voilà jean luc mélenchon il va continuer
la visite jean luc mélenchon alors
l'image est assez cocasse on à l'ancien
candidat à la présidentielle qui se
charge en quelque sorte de la visite
guidée de l'assemblée avec tous les
nouveaux qui découvrent les lieux et un
petit côté professeur mélenchon qui
donne un cours de parlementarisme aux
nouveaux venus bruno cautrès il ya plein
de symboles
dans ces deux images commencent par
celui du point le
jeudi c'est pas nouveau c'était déjà une
image ya cinq ans sauf que là ils sont
plus nombreux ça laisse pas augurer de
débats musclés ce matin des images
proprement vraiment extrêmement
intéressante presque presque mythique
d'une certaine manière on a eu
effectivement cette arrivée en masse des
insoumis à l'assemblée nationale et puis
effectivement le poing levé vous le
dites qu'il ya un symbole à la fois on
est combatif on reste révolutionnaire et
on reste des insoumis même si on rentre
dans les institutions donc très riche de
symboles il ya eu aussi cette visite
alexis corbière commentant lycée
l'historien alexis corbière commentant
devant les nouveaux venus des fresques à
l'assemblée nationale que de multiples
références voilà lorsque le peuple s'est
mis en marche et a fait mettre genou à
terre au roi donc plein de références
étaient très riches défense jusqu'à jean
luc mélenchon dans les travées de
l'assemblée nationale indiquant le siège
qu'il a occupées donc c'était
effectivement une scène extrêmement
riche extrêmement intéressante mais la
dernière fois il avait déjà pardon et la
dernière fois il avait déjà marqué comme
sa part des coûts rappelez-vous jean luc
mélenchon arrivant il voulant brûlés ou
jetés ce drapeau européen qui n'avait
aucune place selon lui dans dans la
chambre donc enfin c'est un peu un
habitué c'est à dire que il est tel que
17 ans donc là vous imaginez bien
17h17 déjà on en parlait beaucoup parce
qu'il s'était habitué à ces coûts de
communication très efficace très réussie
donc là à 90 on peut
et envisager qu'il soit brillant claire
chartier il ya aussi je réagirai sur la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon et
sur ces images
je fais pas de la psychologie de bach à
ça mais il ya forcément une pointe de
regret quand même
et peut être d'avoir choisi parce que
c'est son choix de ne pas se présenter
c'est c'la maintenant alors personne n'a
pu l'imaginer c'est le résultat de ce
second tour des législatives mais quand
même c'est là au parlement à l'assemblée
ici au sénat que le destin des réformes
va se jouer dans les prochains mois et
il n'y sera pas oui et d'ayants il a
fait deux erreurs parce que bon déjà
c'est l'on peut considérer que c'est une
erreur alors il est justifié son son
voile à son idée de ne pas se
représenter parce qu'ils avaient des
choses à faire des livres à écrire les
dons qu'il voulait apparaître comme
enfin approfondir cette cette image de
figure tutélaire et c'est vrai qu'il a
une vraie surface l'intellectuel jean
luc mélenchon cas pour l'instant on
n'est pas dans cette phase de recul
les conférences de presse partout où
c'est possible mais bon on peut
considérer que c'est une première erreur
parce que en effet son groupe a quand
même être handicapé indéniablement et
puis ensuite il a fait une erreur on le
disait à propos du groupe enfin très
très rapidement et ça c'était une erreur
politique et ensuite il est revenu
dessus en disant qu'il fallait qu'il ait
qu'un seul groupe à l'assemblée donc de
la nuque et a tout de suite ses alliés
se sont dit bah non non nous on veut
conserver notre identité de groupe donc
c'était aussi une erreur tactique donc
en fait il a ces derniers temps après
avoir semblé être vraiment très fin
stratège en disant je serai premier
ministre finalement il apparaît
maintenant c'est aussi ça peut-être le
comment dire la cruauté de notre époque
c'est que après qu'on ait en recense et
son sens politique aujourd'hui on trouve
qu'en fait il est plutôt à côté de la
plaque et alors là quand on le voit il
manque pas d'air parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils donnent des leçons légitimité à
elisabeth bornes alors que lui n'est
même pas élu enfin c'est vrai que c'est
il s'est fait moucher d'ailleurs par
gabriela talent et il ya juste titre
parce que c'est vrai que là on retrouve
le mélenchon donneurs de leçons
constamment
et qui veut surtout
une clé ce sera juste un mot
effectivement sur jean luc mélenchon en
fait il faut nous on est des
commentateurs delà de la vie politique
on la regarde on regarde beaucoup ce qui
se passe à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat au gouvernement etc mais il faut
savoir que la politique ne se passe pas
uniquement en fait dans un bâtiment du
7e arrondissement de paris qui est
l'assemblée nationale la politique ou ne
devrait pas se passer que la politique
elles se passent aussi partout ailleurs
devrait se passer partout ailleurs sur
le territoire et c'est peut-être là que
jean luc mélenchon 6 à 6 à mon sens
ainsi à quelque chose à faire s'il ya
quelque chose à renforcer dans la france
soumise dans la gauche mais globalement
partout en politique c'est justement
d'aller chercher en fait les gens
ailleurs en dehors en fait strictement
de genre à doha à la tribu même en
dehors des cours national en dehors des
grandes villes parce que pour l'instant
de proposer c'est parce qu'ils ont tous
bien sûr mais oui mais il en train de
dire en fait est que ce qui peut ce
qu'il est ce qu'il a annoncé ce qu'il a
dit c'est bon je vais en fait je vais
faire de la politique en dehors de
l'assemblée nationale et on peut faire
de la politique en dur de la spéciale
c'est très insultant non mais c'est
important de le rappeler parce que
parfois enfin nous même mois genre à
commenter en sans arrêt ce qui se passe
à l'assemblée nationale au palais
bourbon on oublie un peu que ben en fait
on fait aussi de la politique dans les
marchés dans les sections locales on
fait de la politique dans les dents les
devants devant les usines c'est c'est
important et on en fait aussi ici au
sénat je propose à jérémie lippmann de
nous rejoindre tout de suite bonsoir et
amis bienvenue pour sonder en quelque
sorte l'état d'esprit des députés aient
l'air après ce séisme aux délices
relative oui bah oui le parti a perdu
plus d'un tiers de ses députés la remise
en cause est très forte chez les élèves
une ligne a quand même été martelée par
christian jacob à l'elysée pas de pacte
direct avec la majorité présidentielle
peut être quelques arrangements on en a
parlé mais pas d'alliance clair en tout
cas annoncé directement et ça c'est une
position partagée par une grande partie
des sénateurs
républicains au groupe on nous dit que
seulement 5 6 députés ou sénateurs
souhaiteraient un accord avec le
gouvernement et pour roger karoutchi les
républicains se trouve même dans une
position favorable et selon lui c'est
bien l'exécutif qui devra travailler
avec la droite pour réformer écoutez le
on a perdu les élections et curieusement
on se retrouve dans une situation
politique à l'assemblée nationale meyer
de manière tactique je veux dire que en
2017 mais pour être pour avancer fouette
de quoi je veux dire on peut pas dire et
le gouvernement ne pas se tourner vers
nos indien comment comment vous n'allez
pas bloquer le système ait pu ne faire
aucune avancée ils ont aussi perdu les
élections - cloud mais où ils ont perdu
la majorité absolue et quelle position
le sénat va adopter dans ce paysage qui
complètement fragmenté du côté de la
majorité sénatoriale on l'a sûr il
faudra évidemment travailler avec les
députés pour reconstruire une droite
forte mais finalement c'est l'impression
d'un sénat renforcer qui domine sur le
plan national et même au sein du parti
des républicains écoutez françois noël
buffet et roger karoutchi en parler le
sénat la seule chambre qui sera en
capacité de pouvoir dire des choses
claires voter des choses claires est un
véritable contre-pouvoir est un lieu de
stabilité ce que ne sera pas l'assemblée
nationale faudra que le sénat soit plus
influents et dans nos fédérations et au
niveau national pour participer à la
fois à l'élaboration des projets du
prochain candidat à la présidence et
pourrait participer aux équipes du
prochain président de dlr oui alors vous
avez aussi son délai les sénateurs sur
ces consultations dont on a parlé en
début de débat emmanuel macron qui
reçoit les chefs de partis à l'elysée
ils ont dicté quoi la plupart trouve que
c'est une bonne chose cette idée de
consultation mais pour certains le fait
qu emmanuel macron les dirigent traduit
finalement un signe de fébrilité la part
du gouvernement et on en parlait tout à
l'heure sur le plateau notamment la
place d'elisabeth bornes et bien le
sénateur centriste laurent lafon ne
comprends pas pourquoi elisabeth bornes
ne faisait pas partie de ces premières
discussions écoutez le c'est le premier
ministre qui va avoir à gérer ce
contexte politique à l'assemblée
nationale et à dégager des majorités
donc un peu surpris de l'effacement de
la première ministre dans cette phase de
discussion avec les principaux groupes
pour la première ministre qui recevra
les nouveaux présidents de groupe de
l'assemblée la semaine prochaine merci
jérémy claire chartier c'est vrai que
c'est pas un grand signe de confiance de
ne pas avoir vu les avait deux bornes à
côté d'un des ses consultations je me
demande si c'est pas tout simplement
parce que emmanuel macron et emmanuel
macron en fait est que c'est donc il n'a
pas encore changé c et c'est lui c'est à
dire que c'est lui qui tient les rênes
depuis le début et je ne vois pas
pourquoi il est là je serai dans un
moment à ce point de crise quand une
fois il est en fait le dernier le
dernier maillon d'une commandite d'une
longue chaîne qui en fait existe depuis
1958 mais et une certaine interprétation
de la constitution parce que ça ne veut
pas dire que la cinquième est forcément
donne à ce point tout pouvoir au
président on rappelait dans le second
débat d'un régime parlementaire faut pas
l'oublier en fait c'est un régime
hybride entre le présidentialisme et
donc du coup en fait emmanuel macron il
incarne hossa et par sa personnalité il
a poussé très loin ce qui était déjà
soulignée par jean françois revel à
maintes reprise qui parlait d'un système
de pouvoir unidimensionnel donc en fait
c'est le dernier la dernière figure de
cette de cette culture là et je pense
que d'ailleurs profondément le résultat
de sept de ces législatives c'est ça que
ça veut dire je pense que vraiment les
électeurs ont voulu mettre un coup
d'arrêt à cette dérive césariste de
notre régime ça c'est vraiment l'analyse
que j'en fais donc du coup celle je
trouve qu'il ya une vraie logique à ce
que ce soit et manel macro et pai pai
les a mais il faut que tout change pour
que rien ne change des manuels macron va
faire du conseil national de la
refondation de la commission inter
partisanes sur les institutions du jury
citoyen et au milieu de tout ça une
assemblée nationale qui au fond n'a pas
de majorité absolue ne devient plus
qu'une pièce d'eau gigantesque mécano et
lui va sans doute faire preuve de
beaucoup d'ingéniosité
manipuler ou en tout cas utiliser ce
mécano et qui peut jouer je pensais en
écoutant jérémy nous parler des
réactions et au sénat au rôle de
de gérard h et du président du sénat
dans ces négociations alors il n'y a pas
officiellement il n'y a pas de
négociations il ya un nom le premier mot
qu'emploie christian là comme ces
oppositions bon mais peut-être imaginer
qu'il ya quand même des discussions
derrière et est ce que ça peut être un
personnage important dans ce dans l'est
déjà il va continuer à jouer ce rôle de
personnage clé au fond qui est là à la
fois pour mettre du liant avec au fond
ce qui là à ce qu'il incarne il incarne
quand même pas mal aussi consensus la
recherche du consensus il part souvent
du sénat comme d'une assemblée qu'il
faut c'est différemment de l'assemblée
nationale et on a vu les sénateurs monte
tout de suite au au créneau sur le sur
le thème à voile assez c'est le sénat
qui va être le lieu de la stabilité
alors oui régis c'est intéressant ce que
vous disiez l'instant alors le conseil
national de la refondation on ne sait
pas quand il va finalement voilà à
reporter s'il doit y avoir la perrière
réunion et l haltérophilie a pas de
réunion mais bon si jamais effectivement
il met en place c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites bruno cautrès lorsque cela
veut dire que emmanuel macron va
contourner cet obstacle l'assemblée
nationale par d'autres moyens qui va
inventer finalement avec ce qu'il aime
mettre en place c'est à dire le lien
direct avec les citoyens il il déteste
l'intermédiaire de l'intermédiation
journalistique syndicale tous les corps
intermédiaires et c'est vrai que ce
serait une façon pour le président c'est
ce que vous entendez de contourner
rancière déblocage insurmontable
assemblée nationale oui merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce premier débat